Richard can you please tell us about day
one in your class and what is expected
of the students what is covered and
what's the main idea that you're trying
to establish in their minds that's a lot
of a lot of questions when you say my
class I teach one class every quarter
I've taught it over a hundred times but
I also do teach we're on the three
quarter system we have three ten week
quarters here at UCLA as opposed to the
more traditional two semesters per
academic year so instead of teaching it
if I teach a course every semester it's
it's really every quarter so instead of
two times a year it's three times I also
do teach once a year a big lecture
course which is a rare film course at
UCLA and that anybody who even if you're
not a film major or anybody on the
campus can take that class but I'm going
to assume that we're really talking
about the and that's the fundamentals
screenwriting lecture you know just
explores the the basic issues that lie
underneath screenwriting and it's just a
two credit course one hour a week so I'm
going to assume that by my class we
really build method 434 which is the
graduate number in the catalog for an
eight credit screenwriting workshop it's
the place I'm going to teach you tonight
there are eight writers around the table
and that's significant that we keep the
numbers low so that the the University
and the department and the school and
all of the economic pressure and all of
the heartache over budgets and so on
they've protected us god bless them
because it's essential that they just be
eight writers in that in that class of
that there can be good exchanges among
the writers but also between the writers
on one hand and the teacher on the other
and that's just a three hour roundtable
that meets once a week for 10 weeks and
what I want one of the people who show
up the first day
is a I don't even want to call it an
idea notion what this script is going to
be about and to tell me and and and the
other people around the table in two or
three or four sentences or two or three
minutes which is longer than there ought
to take to tell me what you know tell us
what essentially what you're going to
write about you know if I if the movie
were Jurassic Park I would say there's
scientist discovers that in trapped in
amber you know from thousands of years
ago are mosquitoes that bit dinosaurs
from which you can extract the the DNA
you know of the blood that they left
behind and create dinosaurs so somebody
creates an actual theme park you know an
island they'll off the Pacific in you
know somewhere in the Pacific that is
kind of a theme park or dinosaur theme
park with live dinosaurs from years ago
and all of the complications that ensue
you know that's what we would do that
night and we're gonna analyze broad
notions and again everybody it's not
just the professor but it's a it's a
robust discussion with everybody
pitching in and and you know talking
about the potential pitfalls but
potential strengths and so on everybody
does that that takes up the first night
then thereafter for the first four for
the next four nights twice in each of
the sessions a student takes an hour and
a half first to tell her or his story in
detail this happens that happens that
happens this happens this happens that
happens and I'm not every single detail
but to take a good 15 to 20 minutes to
walk you through the movie describing
the actual incidents and anecdotes and
events that constitute the story the
constitute the plot and then there's
discussion all about that among then the
students will all comment I will keep
quiet and when they're all done I will
and I'll also comment on the comments
and that eats up the next four sessions
by the way we have 8 9 10 even 11 or 12
sections of this class offered every
quarter with different instructors and
what they all share is that it's all
about writing the feature-length
screenplay but otherwise everybody does
it differently and we think that's
really important because it it compels
the writers to find their own voice in
their own methodology and their own
style and their own personality on the
page rather than to model themselves
over a particular mentor again an
authority who knows the answers week
five everybody hands in their pages at
the end of the session and I read them
very very carefully and annotate them I
make notes on them on each and every
page and then week six we we meet not as
a class but independently right here in
this office one on one it takes more
than the three hours that the classes
schedule takes much much of the day but
we work out a schedule and I'll review
the as much as they've handed in you
know some have handed in only six or
eight pages of it'll give me 40 50 60
pages whatever they've handed in I will
have read during the week made notes
upon and then we will be discussing that
in very very close substantial intimate
detail the next three weeks which starts
actually started last week we're doing
table readings the first five pages of
the script really examining the script
up close it's kind of like going into an
art gallery you can look at the painting
from the entrance of the gallery and
I'll see the whole shape of the thing
but if you're a serious artist or an art
lover a scholar of art a student of art
you might eventually come right up close
to that canvas and look at the
individual brushstrokes and so on and so
that's what we're doing kind of that in
the in the class and we can extrapolate
certain principles very effectively from
the context that they're in you know if
there's an issue involving parents
for example kind of tentacle is you know
usually an adverb between parentheses on
the character's name directing the
character as to the way the line should
be delivered and I'm against that I
noticed a chick spear managed to stumble
through 36 or 37 plays without any
parentheticals it never says melancholy
so let's say we see in that context
somebody has some parentheticals well
we'll we'll discuss parentheticals when
they are appropriate with then sometimes
they are but it's rare why they get in
the way and and how they they address
the issues we were just talking about
the collaborative nature maybe the actor
has you know aligned it you think might
be delivered very effectively this way
it might actually play much more
effectively flat and quiet like this
with the emotion therefore being implied
by the artist inferred by the listener
and and the terror you know the the
emotion taking place in the head where
all are should play which is in the head
of the viewer you know not just video
games and computer games are interactive
all art is interactive here's the most
interactive art of all reading I think
you know here's Inka on the page and you
look at this and so these mind you know
in images of sounds and if it's done
well I Roma's and other kinds of
sensations emanate from from that so
that's a long-winded answer to your
question who sort of like what is the
man that that it's our bread and butter
class every writer in this program takes
that class at least I think four times
ambitious students take it seven eight
nine times so I think somebody wants
somehow managed to take a little Evan
times I don't know how he did that but
that means you get you end up with some
scripts to throw away you know every
writer needs a to use some supposed to
find her voice and also you have to
learn how to not become too attached to
what you do
I can't tell how many times I've had to
explain to people it's just a movie you
know it's just a movie people get really
kind of suicidal sometimes over some
some of the issues that arise so that's
sort of the way I don't know if that I
have effectively answer your question I
hope it kind of stumbles that way
you